[Music]
nearly all the islands in the Caribbean
boasts of beaches rhythmic music and
tranquil nights but only one can lay
true claim to be in the birthplace of
the music that rocks the region Trinidad
and Tobago the twin island nation home
of the steel band steel band music
called Pan by the locals permeates life
here from the small fishing villages to
the hilltops
everyone knows and loves the national
instrument the distinctive sound
inspires children and musicians from all
walks of life through the streets alleys
and markets of Trinidad and Tobago you
can't escape the music Trinidad is an
oil-producing nation during World War
two the old discarded oil drums suddenly
became useful an elaborate process
transformed them into world-class
musical instruments pounding the drums
produce sounds that eventually work
their way into everything from Island
calypso to classical music
the steel band relies heavily on playing
by ear most players don't even use sheet
music it starts here with the tuner
locally known as honey boy he has been
tuning pans for decades he pounds his
way to the sweetest sounds of the nation
it's a lengthy process but his
instruments end up with some of the top
steel orchestras but the steel band is
more than music to Trinidad it is an
extension of culture showing the world
what the island can produce
[Music]